it wasn't necessary to wait for the
official election results to be
announced
to know the outcome as a jubilant
president nicolas maduro made ambly
clear
we had the patience the wisdom to wait
for this hour
to wait for this day to get rid of that
nefarious national assembly
that the opposition used to bring the
plague of sanctions onto venezuela
now with this vote we will have justice
venezuela's mainstream opposition
boycotted the legislative assembly poll
which they say lacked the minimum
conditions of a fair and free election
the pro-government supreme court had
taken over three of the four principal
opposition parties
appointing new leaders who are accused
of being pawns of maduro
in addition the court appointed a new
electoral council
also loyal to the government and there
were no independent observers
only staunch supporters like former
bolivian president evo morales
despite threats to withhold subsidized
food boxes to those who didn't vote
the turnout was poor
in this voting center in the makuto
district there is normally a lot of
people
when there's an election today what you
have is a fraud in our country
which has been clearly rejected
maduro's foreign allies like russia
china and iran
will likely applaud the elections which
could give their commercial agreements
with venezuela a stronger legal
framework
with which to circumvent u.s and
european sanctions
but the united states the eu and many
latin american countries say
they won't recognize the new parliament
maduro plans to ask the new assembly to
appoint a special commission
to try enemies of the state especially
opposition leader juan guidor but that
could bring on more international
reprisals
i think it would be better for maduro to
leave gwydo alone
and play cat and mouse with him grab him
by the tail and let him go
what will the world see an opposition
leader who once had 61
support and now has half of that and is
losing more by the day
[Applause]
has been recognized as venezuela's
interim president by more than 50
countries
but his legitimacy has rested on being
the elected leader of the national
assembly
come january when the new legislature is
sworn in
the opposition will lose the only state
institution it controlled
destroying what critics regard as the
last remnant of democracy
in venezuela lucia newman
al jazeera phil gunson is the senior
analyst for the andes region at the
international crisis group he says after
this vote
venezuela's opposition will need a new
strategy to convince voters
and the opposition leadership have said
that they will continue to be
the legitimate national assembly because
they don't recognize this election
either
and they expect uh governments to
continue to recognize by those the
president
i think that recognition is likely to
dwindle over time because of course
the politics is about power and the
power in this country is held by maduro
not by guido
who doesn't even have the keys to his
own office uh i think it's going to be
a question of the opposition going back
to the drawing board really
and devising a new strategy
i think we have to start by recognizing
that most people in venezuela
are concerned about putting food on the
table and
um issues like the like the pandemic
they're not convinced
his so-called interim government really
have much to say
about those those the conditions that
they face which are conditions of
extreme poverty
uh conditions of uh raging epidemics not
just profit 19 or collapsing health
service
collapsing infrastructure all around and
so that there is
very little interest in this election
and there's going to be little interest
i think
within venezuela for the referendum too
because
in the case of this referendum that will
be the possibility of people
voting remotely via internet uh from
abroad where about
five million venezuelans are currently
living in exile